which can make it difficult for people
to find the media they're looking for
the easiest way to manipulate search
algorithms is with a hyperbolic title
that incorporates sensationalistic news
and pop culture events and personalities
will and chat you must now discuss and
decide on an astonishing title for this
episode based on what you think a search
algorithm would be most likely to
promote
this is clickbait
jesus christ
so we gotta come up with a title for
this current episode based on just like
trying to trick the algorithm
okay delightful piece of [ __ ] delightful
piece of [ __ ] i think it's more like uh
some weird thing that incorporates like
uh celebrities or politicians or
something of the time but incorporates
like
like donald trump found guilty of joe
biden right clickbait is usually like
that you'll never believe
you know
you'll never believe what we found
inside of this cake right
that's not a good one i don't mean that
necessarily but that's usually what it
is
10 things to know
what do we call it 10 things to know
about rodney dangerfield's back to
school
because nobody's going to click on
rodney dangerfield back to school it's
got to be 10 things to know it's got to
be something like
did you know 10 things to know about
rodney dangerfield's back to school as
it relates to the january 6th hearings
too long but i see what you're going for
what about what about we just shorten it
and do something like that like uh
uh
uh
chad culchin to appear at january 6
hearings yeah civil war erupts in the
united states that's impossible
geographically
what
uh a physical civil war
something like that though something
about
something like you know you got your
blue you got your blue cities yeah right
you got your largely uh purple
um
near uh proximal areas you know outlying
area over surrounding areas rather nancy
pelosi and then you've got the red sort
of uh
you know country we're just you know
they're just out there trying to get
them farm subsidies and [ __ ] like that
right
we're all hooked up to different news
right yeah and then you know and i'm
just trying to have a [ __ ] bottle and
i can grow some [ __ ] spinach upstate
you know and then the [ __ ] guy says
it was a legitimate election
and [ __ ] mike pillow saying we're
gonna sue the machines yeah
you know and [ __ ] and then bannon you
know [ __ ] steve
seems like a [ __ ] halfway [ __ ]
decent fella he dresses like me
and then he [ __ ] you know he's out
there
he got the same you know he's got that
he's got the two collars and you know a
little bit of a [ __ ] rosacea from the
you know from the [ __ ] drink it's
maybe it's [ __ ] [ __ ] with this
thinker and he's out there
the day after the election is gonna be
[ __ ] [ __ ] you i'm the king and there
was no election
yeah you know and uh you know so there's
not gonna be a physical [ __ ] civil
war now they got that monk and uh
you know
[Laughter]
how about nancy pelosi found dead
that's a little hardcore i'm going for
clickbait dude that's what dudesy
literally said that we have to do these
sensationalistic kind of crazy pop
culture not even not even long island
january 6th guy would go out and nancy
below
um
free bitcoin let's call it free bitcoin
free bitcoin free bitcoin is a good one
it's not nobody gives a [ __ ] about
anymore because it's in the toilet right
now hold on a second dude
hold on dude
well let me tell you something about
bitcoin people are into ethereum now
dude
solana brother
yeah
yeah
sleepy chad hogan who's hulk hogan but
just a little bit sleepy well you just
woke up from a nap
i just took a nap dude why don't we call
it whoa what no way
i think it's going to be something more
specific it's got to be like johnny depp
resus amber heard or something like that
that we they can get that [ __ ] anywhere
this is doozy let's call it chad and
will join isis
is isis still around
i don't i don't know yeah
chad and will restart isis
something like that maybe i don't know i
think isis was eradicated right
i haven't heard anything about isis and
it seems like three or four years yeah
no it has been it has been a while they
were you know when they were first when
they first started up yeah and they were
sawing everyone's heads off that you
know there was a lot of a lot of talk a
lot of hypes around and then they would
just you know throw people in uh
in shark cages and
drop them into a pool anyway
um
how about oh how about something uh
along those same lines you ever heard of
the green river killer
it was like a washington state thing
from the 80s [ __ ] maybe yeah and then
they solved it years later but a lot of
people don't know about it yeah chad and
will solve the green river killer murder
mystery i was thinking it should be
called chad is the green river killer oh
what the [ __ ] we can't do nancy pelosi
is dead but now i'm the green river
killer yeah but like i was saying
something but dancing pelosi is a
current political figure i don't think
that's a very yeah that's not a good
thing to do but what it what is okay no
but it's like is an old murder thing
that a serial killer from 40 years ago
okay no one quite remembers right and
then you go chad is the green river
killer and then people go oh my gosh and
then they jump on the google machine and
they go no that happened a while ago so
it's click bait they listen to the show
yeah they enjoy it and then they go back
and then they go to google and they go
oh no big deal
they literally say in the episode
they're trying to come up with a
clickbait title and that's why they said
chad is the green river killer why don't
we call it chad as a green river killer
not really but he's restarting isis chad
is the green river killer not really but
he's restarting isis how about chad
colchin comma the green river killer
comma is restarting isis and nancy
pelosi is dead dot dot dot and then
small tax in the water in these coming
midterms
i'm now i'm picking up what you're
laying down i actually like that yeah we
want it to i think the bigger the title
the better with the more [ __ ] we can
pack in it the better just so an
algorithm [ __ ] dings and it's like oh
somebody's searching for [ __ ] johnny
depp let's throw that in there
chad culchin the green river killer is
restarting isis his first victim is
johnny depp who is in a cage also nancy
pelosi is dead dot dot dot in the water
these coming midterms too many words
let's just get okay wait let's boil this
down it should just be okay dudesy let's
call
it dudesy can we call it
doozy as the green river killer doozy is
the green river killer how about doozy
restarts isis how about dootsy dudesy
isis jan sixth
dudesy isis january 6.
doodsy explained people are always like
oh dudesy tell us more about this ai
dudesy explained
let's call it ai dude ai now we're
getting somewhere
it's ai restarted isis or something like
that ai starts digital isis in the
metaverse okay i like where that's going
doozy
isis has gone digital in the metaverse
ice has gone digital
ice is in the metaverse that ain't bad
isis in the let's call it chad [ __ ] a
cheeseburger
i mean chad [ __ ] a cheeseburger the
whole podcast
and then
we could the description of the podcast
is just
uh welcome to dudesy hit all our socials
chad takes the top of the bun off of a
[ __ ] cheeseburger
plants his urethra right in between the
[ __ ] processed cheese and the meat
makes a little sound oh
but that doesn't mean i can't [ __ ] a
cheeseburger that's that's randy the
always coming man
that's his [ __ ] catchphrase
all right yeah all right don't turn it
into something dirty
this whole [ __ ] segment is [ __ ] up
you literally [ __ ] said we're calling
the episode chad [ __ ] a cheeseburger
and i turned it dirty yeah because
you're [ __ ] you're doing like macho
man like he's having sex that's not cool
oh my god now i've somehow disrupted the
sanctity of macho man
sometimes you gotta make if you're gonna
make a cheeseburger then you're gonna
[ __ ] it you gotta be careful you wanna
grind your own beef so you know what's
in there you don't just go to am pm yeah
and [ __ ] a cheeseburger number one
reason for that is those microwaves get
the center of those things molt not or a
bean and cheese burrito which might even
be the size of your penis if you slide
that in there you'll get second degree
burns yeah
from that
from that cheese it's not even real
cheese
it's plastic and they're feeding it to
babies yeah you gotta get those corn
lobbies yeah the corn the corn lobby
told us to put fake cheese in the
burrito
and real beans stick your dick in it
snap into a bean and cheese burrito with
your penis yeah
uh
this is tito santana's cup of nacho
cheese in the big time yeah you want to
dip your member in it
so let's call it um yeah you don't want
to call it chad [ __ ] a cheeseburger i
uh yeah sure it's great sounds [ __ ]
fantastic chad culture [ __ ] a
cheeseburger i love it
and we're gonna lead the audience to
believe that
[Music]
thank you moving on this episode is a
[ __ ]
this episode was a menace
i want you to know and i hold you
responsible chad
look at me what have i done such
untoward things were said on this
episode and i'm offended you said most
of them
i said most of them yeah and that's what
i'm talking about by mental illness
exchange yeah mental illness randomizer
yeah it's not just in the doozy verse
yeah you could just trade your mental
illness for another and not even be
aware of what you're saying while you're
making a podcast
which has been purported to detail the
sexual proclivities of a man [ __ ] a
sandwich yeah
this concludes the 19th episode of
dudesy
here's what you do
please tell a friend and break a review
if you like dudes here's what you do
[Music]
please